>>Ankur Kotwal: Welcome everyone to another
APAC Developer Office Hours.
I am joined here today by Anirudh Dewani
he's from Hyderabad--
>>Anirudh Dewani: Hey guys.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Tony Chan from Hong Kong
>>Tony Chan: Hi everyone.
>>Ankur Kotwal: And I am Ankur Kotwal from
Sydney.
So those of you who haven't joined us before,
Developer APAC
Office Hours is all about you asking us questions
live.
And we try our best to give you responses
to them.
So these
are developer questions focusing on developing
on android.
So we have a Google moderator link and you
can post
questions on there and yeah, so you can feel
free to do so.
It's on the Google event, and we'll put the
link again
just as a reminder on the thread for the Hangout
itself.
So with that, let's go to the first question.
Okay.
"So thanks for the answers"--I guess this
person joined us last time--"Sorry I couldn't
join last time.
My question
is related to Secure Element access and selection.
In my case my phone has two Secure Elements
and both are having
the same Base ID's.
Which one will be selected over NFC?"
So typically I haven't seen too many devices
with more than one NFC device so it's pretty
cool that you have a phone
with two.
I should probably clear up one thing, the
Secure Element is something we haven't got
API's for yet.
It's a
secure element because we want to make sure
it doesn't get abused and misused.
So there aren't API's for the Secure
Element itself, but you're asking about how
to access the NFC adapter, well, distinguishing
between those two NFC
adapters Again, there's actually not a good
API for that now.
If you look at the NFC adapter class or the
NFC
manager class, you can say "give me the default
device," but you can't actually say "give
me a specific device."
So right now it's going to give you whichever
one it considers to be the default.
It also depends on what you are
doing with NFC because if you're integrating
with the sort of android beam technology you
can do that, I meant
that's abstracted for you, so just override
the right methods there and implement beam
support that way.
If you have
a really low level NFC, then it's going to
be different.
>>Tony Chan: I have just a quick note, I think
we are jumping between your screen and the
moderator's screen,
constantly,
so maybe we need to fix that because--for
the recording.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Sure.
Thanks Tony.
Okay, next question.
" Low level media.
Will future versions support decoding/demuxing
to byte arrays and encoding/muxing from byte
arrays
or bitmaps or sound samples, as opposed to
the microphone and speaker?"
Anirudh, do you want to take this one?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yep, so the one thing we
would like to say is we don't really have
media experts with us today.
We
are in no way in a session from North America,
about low level media APIs but we'll try our
best to answer these but just
in case we cannot, we'll forward it to our
team at North America.
so, “will future version support decoding/demuxing"--so
right now we have the new low level media
API's , we have a way
of providing a byte buffer to a decoder or
an encoder and then cue the buffer using the
byte buffer which you can
create, so that is one way of doing it.
The future, I don't really know and I guess
we can't really tell you right
now.
[pinging noise]
>>Ankur Kotwal: Thank you Anirudh.
So again, another low level media question.
"Can LibStagefright classes be used in JNI
code somehow?" --it says--"JNI versus Android
source tree
Incompatibilities and stable native interfaces?"
I'm actually not an expert in the low level
media side of things and I actually didn't
understand what you mean by
the second part of the question.
In terms of LibStagefright, I'm not sure,
what we'll do is again--today basically
just so you know, we have a lot of low level
media questions from Marcus in Europe and
unfortunately we don't have
any low level media experts on the Hangout
today.
So what we'll do is we'll forward it to the
engineering team,
and ask the relevant developers and we'll
try to get responses to you in a future hangout.
So I don't know the answer to this particular
question, how 'bout you guys?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Uh, no.
>>Tony Chan: Not for this one.
Also just a quick note for people who want
to look at the list of questions, they can
actually pin the screen for the moderator,
so if you want to, under the people tab, you
can actually just pin down
the moderator screen if you want to look at
the questions.
Just a small tip.
I will take the next question so the next
question is from Bala in Thanjavure:
"Android is now reached all the people who
use mobile phones.
My question is if it goes to an Educational
Purpose
Tablet.
How can we protect them from High maturity
content.
How to block the porn sites and Apps by default
on OS?"
So, first of all, I think this one is not
really a developer question but we're going
to answer this anyway.
So, one thing about maturity content, in Google
Play there is a content filter parents can
enable, so you can
set the setting to high maturity and then
give it a pin, so for children--this way we
can filter out all the maturity
contents from Google Play store.
Another thing I want to point out is this
is not really a specific problem on mobile,
it is just a general problem on
even desktop environment.
I guess also we need to be relying on parents
and also on teachers to help to fight this
issue.
>>Anirudh Dewani: I'd like to add something
to that.
>>Tony Chan: Mm Hm.
>>Anirudh Dewani: I know some educational
institutions that are using Google Apps accounts
as their university
accounts or
domain accounts to deploy these devices, a
provision with those accounts.
So with Google Apps you certainly have
some filters relating to mature content and
so if you are provisioning the accounts for
your students using Google
Apps, you have an actual way of filtering
that at the domain level or at the account
level before android so you can
define some policies there.
The other one is as Google Device administrator
you also have some control over some
policies over the device if the device--if
the account is attached to a domain.
For example you can say cameras not
allowed or stuff like that, but , yeah, those
are some of the other options you can think
up.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, I'll just bring this
back to developers and just say this is why
it is really important when
you
publish an app on Google play that you rate
it accordingly.
It's--one, it's the right thing to do but
two, it's
actually against our policy to rate something
as being universally available when it should
be targeted at a mature
age group.
So just keep that in mind developers.
>>Tony Chan: And one last thing I want to
add is in Google Play we do have policy to
for nudity containing content is
not allowed at all.
If anyone, user or see this content, please
report those to us, and we will take the action
to
take those apps down.
>>Ankur Kotwal: All right, thanks everyone.
So, next question.
"I have several apps on Google Play, but when
I search for my apps through Google search
I realized that other
websites are also selling my apps on their
sites, is there a way to protect my apps from
being sold on unauthorized
sites?"
And the answer is yes.
What you should be using is what we have --something
that we have called License Verification
Library.
I've brought up the page here, which is the
relevant section.
But basically what you are doing is, your
app
is making a call to Google Play to confirm
whether the app has been purchased by that
user or not.
And it's
particularly important that--I mean here we're
talking about the issue where, you know, it’s
been uploaded to other
sites but in general to combat piracy the
LVL is certainly one way to do it.
So I suggest you go through this
Application Licensing section on the developer.android.com
site.
The other thing is--I mean there's a couple
of
things to keep in mind here-- One is that
you want to use LVL to detect whether the
app has been pirated or being
badly sold, but it's important that you don't
just totally destroy the user's experience
of your app because if
they've installed your app and they're actually
using it, then you can see this as an opportunity
to try and convince
them to purchase it at the right place so
link it to the Play store.
You may argue that it may or may not --you
might
not get too many people that will do this,
that convert from being a pirate to being
a legitimate paid user,
but in a way, the way you should look at it
is, even if you only convert a small percentage
of them, those are a
small percentage that you wouldn't have otherwise
been paid for--paid by.
So it's really important that you look at
this but make sure that you don't implement
it in a way that degrades the experience for
the people who've already
purchased it.
So make sure that you think about the offline
scenario when somebody hops onto a plane and
they're
using your app, if the LVL check is not able
to succeed at that point because the device
is offline, don't block the
user from using your app.
So there is a fine balance but the service
helps you.
The last thing that I really should
argue that --
[techno music sounds loudly]
--sorry I'm just going to mute on the Hangout,
Yep.
Sorry Andrew.
But LVL basically we provide it as an open
source
implementation so it's a library; you can
grab it; you can incorporate it into your
app; you need to make sure that
you modify that source code.
Don't just implement it the way it is because
there are people that are writing
automated tools to try and crack software
so if you implement that source code the same
way that it is now-- that
license checking--people are going to defeat
it.
You need to come up with a unique implementation
and that's why it
is open source.
We've tried to be as transparent as possible
there.
Do you guys want to add anything?
Anirudh or
Tony?
>>Tony Chan: I think it's--I think it's good.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Think it's good.
>>Andrew Kelly: Just one thing on that one,
does that mean that you have to include extra
permissions for using the
Internet,so if you've got an app that would
have maybe one or two permissions then you
have to add extra permissions
just to use the Licensing Verification?
>> Ankur Kotwal: I think that is true.
So yes, you'd probably need Internet permission
for that.
Network permission,
yeah.
>>Andrew Kelly: Okay.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Okay.
We have another low level media question from
Marcus.
"Is there or will there be any supported way
to stream live video and audio?"
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: I'm not sure if there are
any high level application API's, but certainly
possible.
I mean many
apps do it.
Many video conferencing apps have streaming
videos and audio.
So I don't know of anybody with a high
level API, that you can just say start streaming
and stuff like that but it's definitely possible.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah.
Okay, next one.
"Will the camera service auto-unlock in future
versions, so a crashed app doesn't block the
camera for every other app
until the phone is rebooted?"
I think Marcus is actually reporting an issue
where if an app that's grabbed the camera
service crashes
that it's locking the other apps from using
the camera.
I haven't heard of this particular issue
and so if it exists, we should certainly--we
will certainly funnel it through to the engineering
team.
And it is
something we should include in our compatibility
testing suite too to make sure that it's generally
reliable
everywhere.
So thanks for that Marcus.
From Andrew: "By default the Droid Sans font
is used on earlier versions of Android.
With the new Roboto font, is
that only used on 4.x devices, or do you also
need to use the Holo theme?
If Roboto is automatically used, is there
a
way to force Droid Sans?"
That's a very good question.
Certainly when you use the Holo theme, it
will use the Roboto font.
I believe the Droid
Sans font is still there to insure backward
compatibility.
Anything else?
Anirudh or Tony want to add to that?
>>Tony Chan: So I guess like if you want to
use the Droid Sans font this is something
you need to override the
theme--the Holo theme right?
View on top of it?
>>Andrew: Yeah, I'm not using the Holo theme.
I was just wanting to make sure when my app
runs on all the different
devices it's going to use the same font across
all of them.
>>Tony Chan: Oh.
>>Ankur Kotwal: It's my understanding that
we still kept the Droid Sans font, and I think
it might even have to do
with which SDK version you're targeting--
>>Andrew: Okay.
>>Ankur Kotwal: --as to whether it picks it
up or not.
Certainly switching to the Holo theme will
enable it.
>>Andrew: Okay, cool.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Okay, low level media again.
"Is there a way to record multiple video streams
seamlessly (without gap between the end of
one and the start of the
next recording)?"
Not to my knowledge.
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: No, I don't know the answer
to this one.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Sorry, we've obviously been
bombarded with low level media questions this
week and we are not experts
at that low level basically.
This seems to be commentary: "The media APIs
seem to be developed for the sole use case
of recording single, short
files to disk and playing it back.
Were other use cases like live video conferencing
on a camera smartphone or simple
video editing even considered?"
So I don't have any insight into what's happened
with the design side of things, but we've
got a video editor on--
that ships with the recent devices and I've
certainly seen video editing software on Play.
So there are people that
are doing this with the high level API's that
we already provide.
So, yeah, I'm sure there's a way to do it.
>>Anirudh: Yeah.
>>Ankur Kotwal: "How do you detect if an audio
codec is not supported?"
Well, for starters, we, on the android developers
website, actually have a list of supported
media formats.
And these ones are the ones that will be guaranteed
to be supported across devices because it's
part of the
certification process for the platform itself.
Now obviously with different versions of Android,
the support has grown
and grown so what I suggest you do is look
through these--this particular document and
then you can see which formats
are officially supported versus ones you might--you
know-- are definitely maybe's, as I like to
call them.
Because
they could be value adds by the OEM's.
>>Tony Chan: I guess Marcus' question could
be also--the other part of the question could
be like, is there a way
to detect the list of supported codecs dynamically
based on the phone?
In Jellybean, we have a new class introduced
called Media Codec List.
So they are causing that class--you can query
the cellphone by what type of media codec
is currently supported on that device.
So--unfortunately it is only
available in API level 16.
But hopefully in the future--hopefully that
will be useful for future phones.
>>Ankur Dewani: Yeah.
All right, thanks Tony.
So I didn't see any more questions on the
thread.
Andrew, did you have
any more that you hadn't put up on moderator
yet?
>>Andrew Kelly: No, uh, I only have one question.
How do I get hold of an Android t-shirt with
Jellybean on the
front?
[laughter]
>>Ankur Kotwal: Uh, not sure yet.
In the past we've --you know we have the Google
store--and we've had them--we've
sold these t-shirts there in the past.
These are kind of hot off the press so we
thought we'd get them out today, so,
uh--
>>Anirudh Dewani: We've also given some of
those through communities, through the GDG's
and G-dots so, yeah, so just
get Ankur on your side and he might just send
you a box of each --
>>Andrew Kelly: I'll catch him at the next
GFG then--GDT?
[laughter]
>>Anirudh Dewani: Okay.
>>Ankur Kotwal: All right.
Well that concludes the Q and A part of the
show for this week, but we wanted to just
cover a few announcements that we've had.
So the first one I'd like to talk about is
actually about this show itself.
There are some changes afoot,
and we're going to be changing the way we
do this show next week onwards, so I don't
want to go into the details
but stay tuned.
We're hoping these will be--that these changes
are an improvement.
We've been listening to all the
feedback that we've been getting and we've
been trying to implement as much of it as
possible.
All right, the other things that I wanted
to mention are relating to some news that
we've had through the week.
Firstly, we've had an update to the Android
SDK tools.
This is mainly just a minor bug fix.
But on top of that, we're
also updated the Android Support Library.
So we have a new notification builder API
to try and sort of add some
backward compatibility for some of the cool
new notifications that we introduced in Jellybean.
So worth your while to
go and update your--through the SDK manager--just
keep in mind that there was a bug that was
there in the SDK manager
where the update may not show up so as the
Post says, just you might need to go into
packages and then hit the reload
option to refresh the SDK manager cache so
that the update shows up.
Next thing--one of my favorite websites is
the Android Design website.
So that's a developer.android.com/design.
It
will add the index.html for you so you don't
need to put that in yourself.
But this has been a great website that we
introduced around December or January.
December 2011, January of this year.
And basically it covers all of the great design
guidelines that we follow when developing
our own Android apps.
So we've had some new updates to this site
that we put live this week, so it's certainly
worth your while to going
and checking those out.
So, things like how to confirm and acknowledge
input from the user, and it goes through all
of this in some great detail, and it will
help you add that level of polish, you know.
When are you asking too many
questions, when are you asking the right questions--as
you all will know you don't want to approach
mobile
development with a very desktop centric mindset.
This particular section is really great for
just explaining how it should
work.
So the same thing when it comes to selection--the
selection site is actually just talking about
how we transitioned to using the
contextual action bar instead of having a
popup for menus.
There is now a new section on widgets, and
including the
updated widgets that we have like for the
gallery for example.
And you know, the re-sizing and so on and
so forth.
So it's really really interesting.
As you all will know, widgets just add a great
user experience.
It's a way to--I
mean--if you think about it from a developer's
standpoint, if a user is putting your widget
on their home screen
you have an opportunity to draw users into
your content.
This is dynamic content that you are updating
and it is so
much more powerful than just having your app
icon on their home screen.
Because you can change the content, you can
alert users to changes that will again, I
mean you're given the opportunity to invite
them in.
So widgets are really
important and in the future, you know, we'd
love to talk to you about how to make it well
known to your users that
you have a widget.
How do you help them discover that?
That's certainly a topic we'd like to discuss
in the future.
So that's widgets, uh, notifications.
Obviously there was tons of information on
notifications before but in Jellybean we added
rich notifications.
So with
these rich notifications you can expand them
and have all sorts of beautiful images and
so again the design site is
going through and describing what that experience
should be like.
The design site is more --is literally for
designers so it's not showing you code but
all you have to do is flip from the design
section to the develop section
to jump to the relevant code pieces.
And, finally, settings, uh, this is actually
a section we introduced a little while ago
but it's still fairly new
and it just talks about how--what things should
be settings, you know, when is it right to
offer a setting for a
particular option?
And finally I'm going to close off with a
section that we introduced called Videos.
So Google IO this year there was
a whole range of videos on the design process,
when it comes to designing an Android app
so we've basically collated
and grouped these Android design videos on
one convenient page so you can watch them
all in one go.
So for budding
designers or Android designers these videos
are really really really useful.
Some great tips there.
So that's pretty much it for What's New with
Android this week, uh so what about Tony and
Anirudh, anything else?
>>Tony Chan: Nothing much.
So--
>>Ankur Dewani: All right if that's it then
thank you for tuning in this week and we'll
catch you next week with some
big changes.
All right, thank you.
>>Andrew Kelly: Cool, cheers guys.
>>Tony Chan: [unintelligible] thanks.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Have a nice one.